so here is some of the worst skit i have
ever seen on snl goober the clown who
had an abortion when she was 23.
[Applause]
so
goober you had an abortion when you were
23. whoa slow down i'm a clown let's
clown around no you think this skit's
going to be an inappropriate clown just
saying inappropriate things right wrong
that's not what the skit is that might
be a funny idea first get nope that's
not what the skit is the skit is an
actual lecture about abortion from a
clown well actually i really don't but
people keep bringing it up so i gotta
keep talking about freaking abortion but
it's a rough subject so we're gonna do
fun clown stuff to make it more
palatable
it goes on like this for a solid four
minutes the best quote from this is
there's one point during this little
skit in which this person says quote i
know i wouldn't be a clown on tv here
today if it weren't for the abortion i
had the day before my 23rd birthday
i don't think you're getting across the
point that you mean to get across when
you say it like that